foreign
[Music]
you know I promised your mom that you
would only use this stuff when one of us
was around it's really dangerous Tech I
know it's dangerous what if the cops
took it from you what if you lost it I
didn't lose the suit you have a suit
wait you have a suit I know how to take
care of myself okay trust me I'm pretty
good at it by now
ouch
look I didn't mean it like that I'm
sorry that's okay it's all right I get
it
I just think you should get to have a
normal life
dad a guy dressed like a bee tried to
kill me in my room when I was six
I've never had a normal life
how about some music
and in that moment all I could think was
how did the Hulk turn me into a baby
will I be a baby forever
am I the hoax baby dad are you listening
to your own book but I was ready for it
no that's uh Stephen this is the radio's
over there it's so weird something's
wrong with this switch it won't turn off
I said turn it off what's that turn it
up all right a little after that a
raccoon from space showed up I don't
think he knew my name I was just happy
to meet a raccoon who could talk
thank you
you're an interesting man
Scotland
you're an Avenger
[Music]
the daughter
but you've lost a lot of time like me
we could help each other with that
how are you I'm the man who can give you
the one thing you want
what's that
time
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care who
this guy is I just lost so much
[Music]
give us a second chance
let me make this easy for you
he will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
it's all my fault
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win
I don't have to win
we both just have to lose
[Music]
I'm sorry Cassie
thank you
[Music]